no son más de las 6 de la tarde pero la
sensación es de medianoche akran recibe
una llamada y organiza el resto del
grupo para salir a patrullar por las
vacío la falta de alumbrado público en
las calles ha hecho aumentar la
delincuencia en este barrio cristiano de
virú Has visto cómo estás completamente
oscuras es un derecho básico que
nuestros vecinos nuestros hijos se
sientan seguros cuando salgan o regresen
a sus casas por eso estamos aquí un
total de 120 voluntarios entrenados por
una compañía de seguridad participan en
esta iniciativa de vigilancia vecinal
para proteger al barrio mariama ha
tenido que adelantar la hora de cierre
de la tienda porque no se siente segura
con la calle oscuras
antes se roba las siete pero ahora no
hay luz en la calle y no vienen clientes
está de cierta me da miedo no hay
seguridad no
mafie Security en un país como Líbano
marcado profundamente por el sectarismo
el hecho de que un grupo de vigilantes
nocturnos reclutado por un importante
partido cristiano haya decidido actuar
por su cuenta ha creado controversias
para Michelle sabarí que vivió la guerra
civil y apoyo actuando cristiano esta
iniciativa de vigilancia vecinal es un
regreso al pasado
es un tiempo complicado estamos sin
presidente ni gobierno todo el mundo
está pidiendo que se desmantele la
milicia que esbolá es peligroso tener
ahora otro grupo encargándose de la
seguridad en su zona
pero el diputado navideño
2020 rechaza que su iniciativa comparte
similitudes con las patrullas durante la
Guerra Civil de Vanesa
no estamos en una guerra civil todo lo
contrario no estamos para reemplazar a
las fuerzas de seguridad trabajamos en
completa coordinación con la policía y
las agencias de seguridad internacional
y más allá de la polémica mientras el
barrio las vacías siga a oscuras estos
vigilantes nocturnos continuarán
resguardando su comunidad ante las
tentaciones de las fuerzas policiales
para dar seguridad